how's it going there citizens of the
reject Nation it's John and Andrew
Gordon back in the saddle once again to
check out a film I am very excited for
it is time for I believe
2016's Shin Godzilla Greg and I have
been checking out the Monarch series
Godzilla minus one is dropping now might
even already be out so we got Godzilla
on the brain Andrew are you excited I am
so excited I want to see the film that
went up against Batman B Superman in
2016 absolutely that that was that
weekend boy duking it out for Supremacy
I just me the year I don't know the
weekend I'm rewriting history right here
exactly leave a like guys for kaiju for
the tradition of monster movies in
general and don't forget to subscribe
the channel hit that notification Bell
so you can be kept up with all the new
releases we got dropping each day here
at the real rejects as always thank you
to prepper for helping us edit down
these highlights it's a tough task and
hey if you want to see the complete Shin
Godzilla experience alongside Andrew and
myself get every little moment that
doesn't make these reaction highlights
why don't you come on over to
patreon.com theal reject where you can
sync up with your own copy of shin
Godzilla got tons of goodies over there
we got shows and movies with reaction
highlights and watch alongs included
exclusively it's blast you'll be super
sexy if you
and uh hey I'm ready to go Andrew you
got anything else to say let's do it
let's do
[Music]
it right to business love it classic I'm
excited not a pleasure craft for
long they left a
crane that's what they want you to
think
damn
nice oh no it's going to say when's this
going to become found
footage
whoa damn oh my God I like how we're
seeing it from people's
povs
right to
business jeez the cinematography it's
liking it so
far it's got to be so horrifying you're
just driving under the tunnel man
yeah
oo it's a bloody
volcano damn God everything is is
already so organized I like that this
movie is wasting no time just getting
right to
business cool a
slide got to have fun in your Kaiju
apocalypse you
know oh no that is so terrifying that
sound that's awesome too
yeah
oh it's good teases though this kind of
feels like like a District 9 Godzilla
movie it's good
comparison
already wasted so much time talking
about this
theme is that where we're getting
Godzilla versus me it'll happen when
they get desperate
enough makes sense but it's uh
fascinating how they're really leaning
on the police iCal side here oh sure
well and just yeah the disaster
management all around yeah no I
mean
uhoh
uhoh yeah stay in line guy we got
bureaucracy to
uphold
damn makes sense usually it's the
opposite way economic first people
second what about that red ring that is
quite a sight
[Music]
though
you're not going to think it's a joke
soon I love these teases look
outside
damn giant Marine creature I would jump
up and say you
see
and bring me my brown pants I was going
to say my pants would definitely be
brown right now I was just about to say
[Music]
that this is an expensive giant SE
creature let just heard it that way make
some signs say go this way yes create a
shoot
oh yeah and it's not deep enough for a
sub
you got to cover all the PES
guys all of
yes oh God fascina whoa it's getting
closer these guys got it the Dream Team
this one guy's on loan from the Star
Wars
Universe I know this
guy this guy's super
familiar hold on to those Scruples
boy oh my God jeez man
what
God I love the disconnect between what's
happening literally right outside and
what's going on in this
office what a waste of time that
was oh
god well this is definitely a deep
fake it's a fair
assumption this is
fascinating I'm curious what they're
going to
say oh my
God jeez I feel like there there is a
definite humorous streak despite how
like devastating this destruction is of
course of course this poor guy
oh oh oh no oh no and and I get the
sentiment want to keep the public calm
yeah but
like so um we live in like a post
cameraphone world this is not going to
last you know what I just said uh forget
that sorry about new Intel is
whoa that is
[Music]
disturbing just assume the experts don't
know a thing this is
unprecedented on the one hand it's the
criticism of like the experts don't even
really know but then also like what do
you
do oh my
God I wonder how long it's going to take
for all this to break down like we're in
so many controlled organized
rooms
oh goodness it's going to have like all
of Japan destroyed by the time you guys
come up with an actual
plan now the problem arises too like can
you fire into civilian
territory
[Music]
that was poetry right there D and
Britt it's what I'm
saying oh
boy what else you gonna
do oh God
oh my God I don't know what you do in
that
situation got to start running there's
some beautiful shots in this
movie oh
god wow that is some Mayhem and
destruction God just the eyes on this
thing
yeah like it it it does look like a real
Komodo or something like that oh no oh
no there's families and people
inside oh oh
[Music]
no get the bug spray out big ass pest we
got
here whoa
I mean yeah what point at this point you
have no choice I love it they're just
super imposing the
handbook if he's not got cause for pause
already
yeah it's a very difficult
decision I really wouldn't even know
what to decide in that second just
because of how unprecedented it
is H beware of unfounded
[Music]
optimism I was going to say in a
situation like this you just got to
trust your own gut and do what you think
is best for you and your family
yeah is this creature like related to
gods or is it be going to be like become
the Godzilla we
know
whoa is he taking a nap is this just
dead there's arms growing
out is it going to like evolve or malt
or
something oh I'm learning to walk
again oh my God it is sprouting some
arms
whoa interesting oh is he getting
bigger
yeah oh
oh fascinatingly odd Choice with the
eyes look at God the inside of its mouth
like it's like it feels like it's just
playing on a speaker in
City Jesus
Christ great attention to details too
the amount of property damage in time of
clean up for this yeah Godzilla
insurance going to be through the
roof you bet it
does like how formation there that was
pretty cool shot yeah and it's so Eerie
with him just standing
there
evu this just going to make it stronger
and angry career
yeah for the
head if you kill the brain then you kill
the ghoul and its motor
functions oh damn
it oh my God
respect that's a fierce trolley problem
oh
oh Atomic breath just love how many
telephones that
involved oh
jeez right at the camera oh my God this
is great they're great at realizing the
scale and it like even though the
effects aren't the most photo real like
it really sells them to the point where
it doesn't matter it looks it looks
great even though you can tell it's
animated oh I get it life has to
continue and Go on
but everything's his business is
normal the rest of the
country
I'm glad the world's chipping in
[Music]
good oh wow I mean it's only 100 I'm
sure it's going to be way more but still
I figur it'd be a little more than that
it's good though it kind of grounds it
makes it more tangible you're like 100
people damn like thousands and thousands
it becomes like less less
tangible
fair you smug he's just got
unfound optimism that's right he's going
to get us all
killed that is quite a a
scene that would not be fun to be part
of that cleaning crew like where do we
start we working on this for the rest of
my life
yeah o it's like a shot out of an old
war
movie on the flip side I'd rather be on
the cleaning crew than on those
boats
I'm curious how they lost him in the
first place yeah his scale just dive
back into the
water uh oh fifth
floor I always want to see how Godzilla
would affect the economy in
census bureaucrats least they admit
it really
big I love these odd like camera choices
yeah spatial povs and stuff like
that going prepared this time wolf nerd
troublemakers academic
Heretics such a great
intro this guy's got
bars oh yeah well his arms were only
like this big so definitely got more
evolving I want to see them try to
communicate with
it
nuclear power
plant did they not see him doing that
Atomic breath thing they did not I
assure you or they're still discussing
it now yeah yeah guess that was just for
us the
audience
oh just some unexplained
radiation it's me when I beat the end of
a tough
game new clear
Vision yeah and he'll be here any minute
to sort your out that's what we
Americans
do what John Goodman in Kong Skull
Island we got to find
Randa just us Japan so win win
absolutely
win-win fraking
yichi
good we want to know everything he knows
red notice isn't that the movie with The
Rock and then r Reynolds I think so out
yeah her was their best film it's a
reference
clearly yes that
too no
need whoa he said that
name he said it he said it is cod
name he gave it an English name that's
the name
Goa
oh
no oh boy that is quite a lot of
radioactive
material that was like piles of
materials surprised only one game or at
least so far I'm sure there's
more yes
yes
God personal
service I love her bilinguals yeah going
to say she's my favorite character by
far so
far we all do after a lengthy series of
phone
calls gamma rays oh that's why it grows
big like the Hulk that's right and it's
shorts ripoff no no just my my my fun
little reference of the
film you have to fire on it to find out
needs more
radiation
[Music]
oh oh
name save goira I mean those people will
be out there too you know they'll be
like this is Nature's plan which
maybe I'm all for not destroying
creatures and all that but when it's
destroying everything that's different
situation
good it's got more business in
Town love this oh he looks he looks
different now yeah definitely looks more
classic Godzilla
yeah ah the
scale just looks like he's made of
molten
[Music]
magma
oh what a shot
[Laughter]
I'm curious if they're going to have any
Godzilla POV shots in the
film although they're doing a great job
at the ground level scale for for sure
oh that trail that is
[Music]
insane oh you're
crazy this is even my final
form is that going to do anything going
in t citizens leave citizens go inside
just go wherever Godzilla isn't at the
moment yeah again what
what tail oh okay that tail right past
the
yeah SCS and flying
around oh man yeah these ground shots
are are incredible though oh my
God Jesus man this are really
impressively
assembled no
pressure unrestricted weapon
use we're all counting on
you a little feel a little bit like 2014
just a little bit little bit but we are
seeing Godzilla a little more than the
version I really oh I feel bad he's in a
tough
position oh boy and little bullets ain't
going to do nothing you need to you need
to send like I don't know projectile
missiles or
something hey it's worth a shot no pun
intended
[Music]
sound the way they prolonged this
too oh boy yeah
I love that they broached the idea like
a little while ago and then we think we
don't need to use it and now we're going
straight to like as much force as
possible nope nope these are just these
are just love Taps to him yeah oh my god
wow right in the
face wow beautiful oh my God that did
nothing that did
nothing they're going to have to science
the out of this
yes nothing else it seems is going I
don't know if tanks are going to work if
missiles don't drop a tank into his
mouth with the barrel pointing
down cuos that oh they're going to shoot
him in the shin
that's why it's called Shin Godzilla
makes sense now someone you could
translate the the the the title for me
in the comments Oh I thought you had it
right there definitely cuz hitting them
in The Shins is going to be the
key nice so
damn
W oh
myness that is so much Firepower doing
nothing
I mean it looks like he's getting a
massage probably
honestly oh my god oh
no he is so damn
strong ah
this guy's having having fun over here
this guy's enjoying
himself oh great
success no Godzilla's like my turn yeah
you
done
a wow wow o oh this poor
guy thank you for all the love Taps felt
good
yeah that camera panning up
too that's awesome I don't love he's
just strolling getting this cardio yeah
just taking a
walk I don't know about you but I view
that as a success sure I we I'll take it
from a certain point of
view we don't want to look weak yeah
that's the important thing let the
Americans take the rap for looking weak
when their efforts are
futile see the night and the blackout
that is and what a clever like effect
solution
[Music]
[Laughter]
too hey you wanted our help this is what
we're doing yeah we come to blow up
that's what we do and we
expect way to do it blow it up real
[Music]
good
yes
props I do like how they're presenting
him as a very honorable human being
seems like a real human with
[Music]
compassion I sure hope so
man you really think doing the car was
the good
idea oh God in the way the sound
all dropped out whoa
whoa if it please we can kill
it that's right that's what we do us USA
I feel like that's just going to get
csilla angrier n dude this is American
[Music]
propaganda thank you godzill for backing
me up not making the
roar oh yeah oh Atomic oh we like you
that oh this
[Music]
music the
jaw
oh
wa secondary eyelid oh damn
this is giving me Vibes of the
hydrogen bomb in Terminator 2
a
Sky beam everyone's favorite the sky
beam but when it comes from Godzilla I
don't mind this a fascinating way they
animate like the mouth and the and the
changing of the beam and all that the
target is shooting some unidentified
weapon from the front bomber 2 and
bomber three will Circle in from behind
yeah it's not a good idea Roger
payback I love I love the American like
actors and voice overs they get
for little stiff oh my oh my
god oh no oh no oh my
god
oh
this is
nuts holy crap
Homeland oh
wow like why are you guys bothering me
I'm just taking a walk yes
welcome to hell ah hell on Earth I
wonder what the count is up to now the
body count you know three 400 people per
second per square
block oh
dormant it's going to say I can't
imagine the radiation levels but don't
worry they'll have a very effective
system for getting the iodine tablets
out
[Music]
there the Prime Minister
yeah this music is so
daunting that's it among other
things
[Music]
[Laughter]
nothing like water to calm the nerves it
is you is there W vatka in that water
not get Hasty right
now okay agriculture
Minister oh Jesus no
that's what I was thinking the whole
time this is not a position you would
want in in a time like
this never said
never
but but seriously though like we're
we're in a joking type of
mood oh hell of a
speech
Montage just take a giant chainsaw and
cut the from the neck up yeah or like a
giant swimming pool filled with water
put his foot in it you know maybe he'll
get embarrassed and leave the is a
movement centered in China and Russia to
take gazer from under the control of the
Japanese government and put it under the
control of international
organization as for this government we
strongly hope that Japan and the US can
perfectly control godilla together
control wof oh no man as the Army
Express as the backbone of the
government we have to respect the
offer the at the center of decision
making of that we
will I like it it appears that Godzilla
has something like a built-in phased
array
radar he's dropping skin I would assume
he's evolving more he's like molting
again
again uh yeah about that part nope
nope if there's even a 1% chance
Godzilla could end up on the coast we
need take as absolute certainty the film
I referenced earlier yes the best
film at some point we need to come to a
realization weapons are not good on
especially new
[Music]
clear great
out yeah it is a great cran out
interesting shot yeah I like how it's
staying too on on a tracking cran out
yeah without
cutting I need emergency Powers then I
will become the emperor
is oh boy
oh
[Music]
nope I don't blame
you that's what you think
debatable you have the science-based
evidence
to oh
yes they're going to freezing like
Megatron was frozen at the beginning of
Transformers that's what we
need
dude you're going to lose the world if
you don't yeah I mean I don't think it
don't matter that much
anymore see sciencing the out of it
I mean it seems like the only thing that
could possibly
work I like this music
choice
damn uhoh the reboot has
started
oh we think our time for the nuclear
strike against Godzilla has been being
decided countdown will begin in 5
minutes H it's not that
hard oh my goodness yeah I was going to
say what evacuation plan can you come up
with that isn't just going to lead to
endless
gridlock why not just bring it
now
you scratch my back I scratch
yours he created
Godzilla
[Music]
there's something to
that or perhaps it's meant to be like
placed on top of a different paper and
they'll both line
up what you got me ah
of
course
wow
whoa
wow sure as many raw materials
do
no whoa nice that's that's a cool
POV whoa I knew computers had a mind of
Their
Own
some kind of
test
yeah and it's a kinky
plan
I got
time it's okay
man yeah we don't have that much time
our friends are progressing with an
effective deep freeze plan I think this
country is betting on it and you're
raising that bed also I see know she
wants to tell to f off so bad me I'm
okay but you with your fastidious career
and the Patterson name mud will stick
yeah think about your career right now
becoming president in your 40s will
disappear this is about you hey
Koko good luck yeah
[Music]
yeah every time this music CU starts I
think it's going to turn into the aam
theme
song getting done music came
yeah I was going to say do you need a
country to be a PM people keep saying
that like you think about your career
down the line like dude we're not going
to have a place to
be before the Americans come in and blow
it all up
just seeing it off in the background
from that distance yeah it's so
imposing ready
break oh my
God
who
wow
wa wake
up that's why they call it Shin Godzilla
just drive those trins right into his
shins
oo how how far is the
[Music]
reach yeah watch your
baby we must continue I mean variables
are
inevitable jeez
man again like like how far like are
people seeing these beams over Europe
and America and everywhere else like at
least the the nearby Asian countries
must be seeing this oh no from it tail
get the whip oh my
god oh damn
oh mouth and tail same
time both
ends God damn there you
go I like that the the purple flame is
like the
hottest
fun who
Damn
no oh my God o dominoes I going to say
is that a domino effect we're
having
yeah that's insane oh wow oh
I feel bad for
[Music]
him let's go crane
team oh putting the coagulation in him
yeah just drop those pills in there drop
time to take your medicine Godzilla drop
drum after
drum
oh
[Music]
wow this is like a a city scale
surgery oh God oh God and now we got to
watch the loading
bar ah
I feel like there's again going to
be a a delay it it worked but it's going
to be a
delay ah God what a fascinating strategy
Just Launch public transit at
it
who this is an effective bomb I got to
say
oh oh my
God
this is the baddest ass sequence I've
ever seen involving
cranes which you know I can think of a
couple they must had some extra no it's
interesting I kind of feel bad for
Godzilla but obviously I do want
them a look like he's drinking it
[Music]
now please
work
yeah
oh it cannot be
destroyed
oh no Godzilla
freeze got to take a picture of
you
negative
oh
it's a fascinating
movie that's what I want to see a sequel
where we just watch the cleanup happen
yeah and a new system of politics
[Music]
instilled you picking up what I'm
putting
down
yes it
will I mean the world deserves to
know oh that'd be
cool of course I mean let's be real
right and I will own
nothing oh good
man we got
beef oh oh
whoa
what what what is what I don't even know
what that was growing out of
it I have so many questions yeah
I'm like what kind of what kind of
mutations are those mutations that were
taking place still evolving you know
from all the nuclear input or is that
like like beings that were like grafted
on just from all the different
explosions and and and uh
destruction it was from that cranial
surgery and stuff just started growing
in funny places you know when you get
surgeries uh not at the right times
things start happening sure sure but you
know before we go any further the thing
I'm I'm not uncertain about is the best
place to support the trannel and get the
trannel the channel and get yourself uh
a nice fresh drip in the process
Andrew's got the Classic tickets over
reject Nation shop.com probably be good
if I named the website rnation shop.com
if you want to grab yourself some swag
we got the who influences the
influencers te we got uh space babies of
the Galaxy we got the new boys inspired
America's ass t-shirt tons of good stuff
over there so uh if you want to support
the channel and rock you know like
display your pride in the nation reject
uh head on over there we very much
appreciate it but anyway I I I cut you
off no no no you're good you're good uh
no I really enjoyed the film uh I love
the look of Godzilla in this and the way
he evolved it was really unique uh I'll
go more into that in a little bit also I
enjoyed the political satire just all
the how we were just so focused on all
the uh the politics of everything just
like and again it was a very
unprecedented event so it's like I did
not envy the Prime Minister just anybody
in that situation I'm like I would
literally not know what to do obviously
maybe the logical thing to do is just to
attack but then again you got to view
collateral damage and other things like
what do we do in a situation like this
this is so unparalleled and
unprecedented so um I just thought the
you know the storyline like were the
characters like you know great or
anything I mean I'd say there was one or
two characters I really actually enjoyed
following for the most part uh you know
the guy who came up with the uh the
coagulation with the team and all and
then that other pret woman who wanted to
have the ambition of becoming president
I really liked her character a lot um
but just from the political standpoint I
actually really enjoyed it just you know
giving us that Insight of what would
happen if a monster of this mon of this
scale uh you know decided to attack a
major Metropolitan uh City and all so um
from that point of view I really enjoyed
the film and just again the a lot of the
cinematography I really appreciated
there was just I mean just a lot of the
POV shots and also there was that one
specific shot where they were just
having that conversation and we were
doing out on that tracking shot just and
also too inside the computer and I could
go on and on about the cinematography
but what did you uh think of the film no
I loved it I I loved the way that this
was constructed and the way that yeah it
brought all of its elements together to
create something that's definitely
within the tradition of of you know the
Godzilla Legacy that exists now but also
that feels very kind of invigorated and
fresh and uh and yeah there's something
real funny to me about watching this
because obviously there are elements of
the ecological commentary and the you
know commentary on nuclear
proliferation that Godzilla movies often
touch upon but I feel like there's also
a metal layer of like
the legacy of Godzilla as a figure kind
of I I don't know if that's just me but
I kept catching elements folded into
this where I'm like we got Japan and we
got America and they're all kind of
dealing with this creature and like
there's that point where they're like oh
we're getting this Intel from the
Americans and I know that there are you
know backs and forth uh forths in terms
of the rights and like how uh in the
American movies they can use Godzilla
versus in the Japan uh the Japanese
movies and stuff like that and uh and
like what's accepted as part of the lore
and the approach here versus there and
uh the fact that you do get this like
heavy American presence uh partway
through and continuing through the movie
I thought was kind of a neat uh sort of
funny little thread especially with like
the different formations Godzilla goes
through and uh yeah just the debates
about the nature and obviously we live
in a different point in time where you
know the the original film you know is
is largely in reaction to atrocities
during World War II and Pearl Harbor and
all that stuff and and you know nuclear
uh just the nuclear situation in the
world has changed but that's still very
much sort of the Catalyst for it all and
so uh it's interesting then that you
would have this
scenario and it didn't go on the nose in
terms of the past history but yeah this
scenario of like the Americans are
coming in they're like we got to Nuke
this thing now yeah the American thing
to do yeah and then you know them racing
to get this alternative solution
together that by the end of the movie
you're sitting there going like this
isn't like the
solution and it's interesting that they
would arrive you know this is a
temporary solution and it's interesting
that they would arrive at the idea that
like yeah we're going to have to learn
to coexist because as of now the only
way we have found to mitigate any of
this creature's progress is just to to
freeze it you know to stop it exactly I
was waiting for him to say welcome to
Godzilla World um but uh yeah no I mean
from at least my recollection of what
I've seen in the American films of that
I watched in Godzilla like most of the
time when they've at least uh I know the
film we we don't want to talk about the
1998 film they used uh actual weapons
and that was his weakness uh in in that
film my only yeah exactly but I I do
like in this film and this approach
where like that literally does nothing
it's like love Taps to him um and I love
the idea of actually using our brains
and sciencing the out of it not say
that again but um I I do love that whole
idea of you know finding a different
type of approach and way because that's
that becomes formula at some point I'm
like all right using weapons again to
stop but also that and oh sorry sorry I
was just going to say also too I like
that that's a source of strength for him
too when you're giving when you're
shooting nuclear weapons at him he could
just use it right back at you I just
thought that was really interesting and
unique as well too another one of those
things though that that and I'm trying
to remember where this would be I mean
we're only I guess right after Godzilla
14 this is right after 14 so I'm
wondering where we are in the American
lore with them because they because the
American movies have brought in that
idea of like oh he feeds directly on
nuclear energy and it certainly yeah
like sort of comes in here and then by
the end they're sort of like again that
metal layer came back up to me where I
was like they're kind of acknowledging
that like all we can do in any of these
movies is temporarily stop Godzilla
because Godzilla will always come back
and in that way we are coexisting but
but yeah I like the way that this
combined those random flavors that I've
been harping on with yeah like this very
uh realistic semi docu style like there
are a lot of elements that reminded me
of like a District 9 approach where
you're going to just so much uh you're
you're doing semi documentary but you're
also just pulling in like footage that
looks like it could have been sourced
for some kind of news report but then
you're going narrative and and as as far
as characters go like I don't begrudge
this I think this movie brought an a
nice approach to that because you know
it's well documented that the second you
start talking about human characters in
any Godzilla movie everyone you know
kicks in the door and it's like nobody
cares exactly and so like I don't mind
in the least that we didn't like have
some kind of central you know
protagonist I mean we kind of do there
are a couple people we focus most on but
I liked that this represent presented a
collective effort and I'm sure um in
some ways this reminded me of watching
uh what was that show called all of us
are dead in that so much and I'm sure
other things have done this too but
that's you know sort of the touchdown
that r that Rose to mind for me where
you're watching the the
downsides of the system as it exists uh
in Japan here for this example uh you
know the their democratic system and the
ways in which it's you feel for the
struggle because you're like I get why
we need all this bureaucracy and
clearance in theory I get why we need to
have experts and everybody kind of
coming together and sort of breaking
down the situation and figuring out what
to do but at times you don't have the
time for that so you do sit there going
like man they they've wasted a lot of
time by going like okay let's get a plan
together based on what we know and at a
certain point you're kind of sitting
there going like I don't know like
nobody seems to know because every time
you go with your best plan it's just not
applicable you know and so them coming
in towards the end they're like you know
this is the one thing that we know like
you know we got to Nuke them cuz nothing
can withstand the heat of a
thermonuclear weapon and that's one of
those things where yeah it's like the
hubris of thinking that you know and so
like yeah you can't necessarily just
come out and be like hey this is what's
going on but in some ways I think the
argument exists that there's got to be a
more efficient way or there's got to be
a more direct way and that you know
sculpting and wrangling and trying to
control the image and the information is
this perilous process because on the one
hand yeah I understand why you wouldn't
want to just go on TV and be like holy
there's a Kaiju outside but at the
same time I think the the great you know
a great thing about the First Act or so
of this is that you are just knees deep
in this contrast of like every time they
cut outside it's utter chaos and every
time they cut inside it's a bunch of
people very remove like focused on this
but very removed from the reality of
this and I love the way that it early on
they're strategizing and you're just
watching as these strategies are being
completely outmoded like in real time
right there's only so much you could do
I mean the Prime Minister was saying
that there's no way you can come on land
and then a half a second later he's
coming on the L I mean again it's so
unprecedent it's like that's why I was
like I have no en
for what is going on in such crazy
chaotic time I mean this is not
something that you can prepare for well
it's unprecedented yeah and I think the
the argument then becomes like at a
certain point it might be better to just
come out and be like this is
unprecedented and we have our best
people on like again statecraft I don't
know how you would qu the panic but yeah
being able to come out and not waste
time and Reon I get you have to try
stuff but at the same time being like no
we're confident it's not going to come
up on land for for reasons that we've
contrived because nothing like this has
ever happened before for sure and in
regards to your comments earlier about
you know in films like in these Godzilla
films like yeah we don't want to focus
too much on the characters we I'm fine
when they no no no no I was I was
totally fine with it like and again it
was really more about those I mean again
it was a collective Ensemble more so or
not that but like just really focusing
more for sure but just focusing really I
mean I felt like those two were kind of
the main stars if if you will of those
characters which I I found you know I I
didn't find that to be unnecessary or
anything which I was fine with it's well
in the tradition yeah for sure but I
like that we were just staying more on
on the political satire and we were just
focusing on that and then obviously we
get our Mayhem and our destruction and
this full scale stuff and all our
cinematic shots so you know from that
from that standpoint I I had no issue or
problem with what we got from a
character's perspective no totally and
there's so many characters and so many
units and they do a good job for the
most part of uh you know is it would be
easy to lose track you know of of all
the different places we go all the
different teams and groups and I thought
they managed nicely to you know not make
that too confusing and I I really like
the sort of race between you know
building arms against Godzilla but then
also uh you know taking this theoretical
this you know it's such a great little
movie to viice of like here's this
mysterious bit of research left over by
this guy who has a whole relationship to
at least aspects of this scenario and
all we've got is this to work from and
then yeah them coming up with this
origami concept like there's so many
things I would love to go back and
examine that was probably one of my
favorite sequences when they are like
they they're folding the paper and
they're solving the riddle like that was
you one of the more unique perspectives
I thought of the film as well yeah yeah
and I mean I like that this has that
element of sat and I think certainly if
you are Japanese and you live in Japan
you will probably note a lot more
nuances of what this is saying about you
know the political system the the you
know Reliance on protocols and certain
uh honorifics and traditional I love
that that bit it's a very American thing
so it works I think on a dual level
where she's like can we drop the
honorifics I'm not good at that and like
you know and uh and yeah it's one of
those things where you're like well
truly it's not that important you know
like right now in this crisis mode like
it's not what we should be focusing and
spending time on and I thought the movie
overall did a nice job with the
satire because they they they put you in
both pairs of shoes I think you're
sitting there going oh guys you know
these 20 phone calls to get to this
conclusion is not really working but
also uh it doesn't go so broad as to be
like like ah look at these and
it does make you feel for just the sheer
scope of the situation and the sheer
yeah unprecedented struggle of figuring
out any plausible direction to head in
and I thought the film you know did it
good to its credit did a really good job
of giving me a little
sympathized Zilla too there in the end I
mean as a force of nature yeah yeah for
sure like I mean it's just doing what it
was built to do you know kind of thing
wasn't trying to you know do destruction
on uh you know Mar like not for the sake
of blood lust of course of course it was
just doing what it was born to do I you
know from all the nuclear waste that was
left on the ocean floor that was born
out of and uh you know from that
perspective I I did feel bad for him uh
obviously you still got to stop you
can't just let him roam around and do
his thing but uh yeah no I mean from
that perspective I I did definitely feel
some sympathy I'm like you got to stop
but I still do feel bad you know type of
thing so well it's nice cuz yeah it's
like Godzilla this force of nature the
origins have been updated slightly to be
a bit more I guess ecologically minded
in that it's like nuclear waste was
dumped here and some ancient creature
soaked it up this is men caused this
yeah so there is still you know the
looming you know origin of the franchise
itself again with you know the you know
the nuclear drop but you know it's
updated here to something that makes a
bit more sense for then the Lord that
they apply with like oh it kind of can
if evolve back and forth depending on
you know which setting it needs to be
and whether it's underwater or whether
it's on land and you know oh it it it
evolved in this one way and now needed
to regress in order to cool itself down
just some interesting flourishes of the
the science and L like the science
fiction of Godzilla here and so getting
I thought I mean the effects on the
creature were really well handled
because they're not always the most
photorealistic you've ever seen however
I think the combination of the editing
the cinematography which is which I
think is really great throughout and is
great at ramping up and easing off the
gas um and even the choices of music all
that stuff like all the the film styles
are great and and yeah the action and
the monster Kaiju stuff is really
striking fantastic because yeah when
you're early on and you've got that that
you know earlier stage or or you know
that regressed cool down phase he's in
like it is so strange and it's almost
like some kind of internet meme you're
watching that some guy who just has
really good effect skills mocked up
where it's got these big disconcerting
eyes and it looks more like a lizard you
know it did take me a at first myself I
was like ah okay this is the look we're
going for then I but then I uh grew a
likeness to it and then the evolved look
I was like okay this is more traditional
Godzilla but and that's monstrous and
Eerie just like when it's like barfing
blood from its gills and stuff like that
and then yeah that was terrifying and
then as it takes further form you know
it starts to resemble in a much more
nasty just kind of like someone
scribbled the concept art you know in a
fit of anger just like this sharp molten
looking thing and yeah it does a really
I think nice job of portraying it as
this this this force of nature that is
not concerned morally one way or the
other with what's going on on the
mainland but also yeah by the time
they're nuking it and and you know
pumping it full of coagulants you do
start to feel for it and and I think
that kind of enhances the idea of what
this Godzilla is doing which is yeah
it's not as much about one specifically
aim towards one particular traumatic
moment in history that's in there but
now this is more of a you know
shapeshifting and ever sort of uh uh uh
what am I trying to say it's like an
Ever
evolving threat that we now have it's
like we created this or we unlocked this
Chain Reaction now we have to coexist
with it and I think that nicely keeps in
line with the logical stuff as well as
the aspects that are commenting on you
know human society and how we respond to
disasters and how we prioritize who get
saved how we you know attack all that
stuff yeah I have no doubt the writers
of this film saw Teenage Ninja Turtles
Secret of the use and then they saw how
the turtles stopped Tokar and razar they
put the fire extinguishers in them and
froze them and then that that's how they
came up with the just one big om yeah
exactly exactly there's my reference for
the the video yeah buddy well all right
any stray thoughts before we hit no just
uh I this is really I believe my first
introduction to uh you know God Japanese
Godzilla film so I really enjoyed it it
was great again I loved all the
political satire stuff was fantastic uh
I loved the evolving of Godzilla great
stuff and then again the the science
based stuff and I love how you know just
physically trying to harm it without
doing the science stuff like just was
love Taps to it I thought that was
really unique and great too so just a
lot of great stuff that I enjoyed and
the cinematography is so unique like the
POV shots going inside the computer the
pan out shots so many different elements
of this film that I I really enjoyed
absolutely man me too I'm glad we
finally saw this this is definitely like
one of the most striking and and
gripping Godzilla movies I've ever seen
and it's really cool after seeing so
much of the monsterverse stuff recently
to come back to to just to see how you
know The Originators of this prolific
character franchise Etc you know
redefine it for a new age and I think
that's something about Godzilla that
will always endure is like every
generation you can kind of update it
into something quintessential but fresh
and and new and and fully in in
utilizing all of the latest you know
approaches to film um so yeah I thought
this was really terrific what did you
guys think leave us your thoughts down
below and uh Hey last but not least
let's do a little patron of the day
shout out Andrew Let's uh what's a good
scenario that we can put Adelia
Chamberlain and michale Linden in it's
Godzilla related uh uh scenario what do
you think what do you think a good
scenario yeah they're like trying to
fight Godzilla and and uh here hold on a
second nothing's working right now a few
moments later all right Andrew let's do
uh let's do male Linden and adilia
Chamberlain and I've taken the liberty
of writing up a little prompt you know
how we do nowadays Chad GPT I have a
YouTube channel absolutely that's what
we get paid the big bucks for to to to
type a prompt uh so I want to give a
shout out to two of our loyal patrons
AKA super sexy rejects their names are
Mel Lindon and Adelia Chamberlain and we
love them male is from Sweden he loves
James Bond and Adelia is a movie trivia
genius and a very caring human being
depict a short scene only dialogue of
them trying to take down Godzilla using
only triv
are you ready Andrew I am ready you're
going to be would you want to be M or or
adilia I'm down with either I love movie
trivia and I love James Bond I'm good
with either okay um I will be Adelia
then you can be M do your best sweetish
accents oh thank you all right Adelia
remember how Bond outsmarted his giant
enemies we need that kind of wit
here yes nodding eyes sparkling with
excitement absolutely let's use the
classic Godzilla versus Mecca Godzilla
trick we need a distraction something
big and flashy like the time Bond used
his Aston Martin's gadgets to escape got
it let's set up a series of large MIRS
around Godzilla the reflection might
confuse him he brilliant and remember in
Godzilla king of the monsters how they
calmed Godzilla with the Orca device
let's use a similar sound frequency to
disorient him that sounds so annoying
even Godzilla can stunned it what about
the Jaws same song played
backwards perfect that's our secret
weapon a mix of bonds cleverness and our
movie trivia knowledge let's do this I
love it and and Chad GPT even took the
time to send us a little addendum saying
the scene Blends male's love for James
Bond and adelia's movie trivia expertise
in a playful and imaginative way
suitable for your YouTube channel shout
out thank you
chat and uh and yeah I mean I guess I
would love both of you on my Godzilla
survival team by by this shout out it
seems like adilia might be a little bit
more she might have the more pertinent
knowledge just to you know I don't know
how many gadgets we're going to have at
our disposal but you know we need a
debonaire guy as well who can get the
Intel so I appreciate you both we love
you guys you guys are some of our most
long enduring and supportive patrons and
and in all seriousness we appreciate you
very much we love you guys and uh and
yeah in this Thanksgiving season I don't
know exactly when you are going to be
seeing this but in this Thanksgiving
season we are very thankful for you guys
and I hope you stick around for many
moons to come be well people and we'll
catch you on the next one much love
cheers